make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into the
boys by Garth Ennis and this is kind of
a funny situation right because this is
the miniseries Highland laddie and I was
going through when I was reading this
because of course he is from Scotland he
was using Scottish phrases or Scottish
slang like to Kent EO and then ke and
and like I have used context to figure
out that means to know and I was like
huh that's interesting like I guess kin
means no and I guess it's there there
there slang words if any of the guys
here from Scotland like throw some slang
words in the comments and let us know
what it means I kind of throws me off a
little bit so I'm trying to understand
your language try to understand her
slang and and hopefully I can if you
guys if you guys help me out a little
bit but if you guys remember in the last
video that we did essentially Huey had
walked away from Annie right here we had
learned that Annie had basically given
to a homeland er a train and then to
black noir in order to get herself on to
the seven and he was somebody wasn't
able to process it and lashing out
saying some pretty horrible things he
essentially instigated a breakup and
then walked away and so what this does
is it basically picked up with him
traveling back home again right going
back to Scotland and revisiting his
family kind of getting back to his bases
and this is a cool little thing here
right because he spend time with his mom
he spends time with his dad now keep in
mind these are not his actual biological
parents right Huey doesn't know who his
biological parents are and for the most
part he doesn't really care right I mean
these are the parents that raised him
but the issue with this is that he gets
a little frustrated with how his parents
treat him and so far that his mom really
kind of dotes on him and it kind of
babies him to a degree now that'll
become a little bit important later on
down the line but what he does is he
basically picks up with a killer with a
friend by the name of Dean and then with
a friend by the name of Bobby now I say
deep because he says that deed is short
for detergent because apparently like he
just never really used it he just you
know smelled all the time but Bobby is a
bit of a different story
from what seems to have gone on in the
time that he's been away which has been
about seven or eight years Bobby has has
basically started dressing up as a woman
so it kind of takes it takes Huey by
surprise a little bit which is pretty
interesting to see his reaction here but
if for him it's kind of getting back to
his roots right now this is something to
notice here how he relates with his
friends right it's kind of like hey you
know it's good to see you guys again and
it's almost one of these things where
he's kind of nostalgic for days gone by
right he's estatic for time in his life
which really seemed to be a lot simpler
now in reality and that's that's kind of
the funny thing about nostalgia the
important thing to understand about
nostalgia is just because you remember
things being a certain way doesn't mean
they were that way it just means that's
how you remember it
and when people always say well I wish I
could go back to a time when I was
younger and the world was a lot simpler
the world wasn't
anyway when you were younger if you were
just too young to understand how
complicated it really was and so that's
really what's going on with Huey for him
going back to a simpler time to a degree
when he was a little kid yes things were
things were simpler and so for our visit
his responsibilities and his perceptions
of the world but the reality is the
world was just as complicated as it ever
was
he just didn't fully grasp it he wasn't
really exposed to it and so spending
time with Bobby and spending time with
with detergent ultimately he kind of
ends up going about doing his own thing
and comes across a guy named mr. Vickers
who's basically painting a picture on a
beach and it's kind of a cool thing
because the two of them start talking
and indeed like Huey starts talking
about nostalgia and one of the things
that he says is he you know coming back
here he looks at his friends and it's
kind of like he envies them to a degree
right because they've continued on you
know for them things haven't changed
everything's the same way that it was
before but for Huey everything's changed
he's really starting to see the world
for what it is not the way he envisioned
it to be right not this kind of
isolationist a sheltered mindset that he
spent so much time having when he lived
out in Scotland and so as a result of
that it's almost a little more you know
a little too much for him to grasp but
mr. Vicar says the exact same thing he
says look your perception of this isn't
really because of the way things are is
because you're looking at the world the
way you see it now and you're looking at
the world the way that it used to be and
for the people here they'll continue on
their normal lives right they'll
continue on doing their normal thing and
in the world won't really change for
them because they haven't seen the same
kind of things you have but for you the
world has changed and it's not a bad
thing you just have to learn how to put
it in perspective and so because of the
fact that mr. Vickers offers this this
kind these these little words of wisdom
here these little tidbits to him what he
basically does is really kind of form a
bit of a friendship with this guy
insofar as they kind of visit each other
off and on and they start talking about
these little individual things that they
have going on in their own lives and
really it's Huey kind of talking to
Vickers and dummy on each part of his
life right you know one of the things he
talks about is a frustration of his
parents that he loves his parents but
they baby him by they baby him in a lot
of different ways he talks about his
friends and even when he got a hard time
from detergent and Bobby it was really
more of them just giving him grief you
know busting his balls because that's
what friends do whereas being as part of
the boys there were times when he was
just downright humiliated but the
reality is that Hughie's kind of looking
at it through the wrong perspective
right he looks at it as though the boys
are somehow have it out for him or
they're trying to try and screw him up
whenever Jana did they consider him to
be a friend right
hence the reason why Mother's Milk
opened up with his origin and the
friendship and the female why they gave
the origins their stories to Huey is
because they view him
in a lot of ways with some camaraderie
some Brotherhood that kind of a thing
and so again you know it's one of these
things where Huey kind of has to keep
things in perspective sort of get things
lined up and focus on the world the way
that it needs to be or at least the way
it is in the right frame of mind and so
from here you switch over to this small
little thing right which would become
important once you get to the end of the
story but you switch over to this small
little thing with a guy by the name of
topic now topper is basically a drug
supplier right and he kind of has an
international scheme going on and what
he does is he basically mingles cocaine
with compound V and then sells it to
people and so it basically gives them a
bit of a high and also some of the
effects of compound food now he's got a
couple of guys who were basically in
this part of Scotland who were kind of
his suppliers right and are not really
suppliers his dealers in the sense that
he gives us them they basically deal it
out then they come back with the money
and these guys start to get a little big
for their britches right they start
saying things like well if it wasn't for
us you wouldn't be able to get these
drugs out there right you wouldn't be
able to get people to buy them for you
or anything like that so I think we
deserve a little bigger cut than what
we're currently getting right now and so
as a result of that what he does is
Tupper calls it as nice a woman by the
name of Sarah who's a pretty she's a
pretty hefty size right she's a pretty
big woman who's also got an enormous
pair of shears and puts them up to one
of the henchmen and ghostess start
cutting off his face and these guys come
to their senses pretty fast and like
okay so like we'll keep on doing what
we're doing we'll take a pay cut even
you know we'll keep on doing what we're
doing and yeah like what we'll call that
a day and that'll basically be it right
that is kind of mind their own business
from that point going forward and so
what it does is it switches over to this
a little bit of an origin about Hughey
and what he does is he starts talking
about his aunt Mary and what he says
that his aunt Mary was a small woman she
really seemed to show symptoms of like
dementia or Alzheimer's or something
like that loss of appetite things along
those lines but one night he we
basically wakes up to like sudden
screaming and some blood that's
basically around different you know of
one of the rooms of the house and so for
the most part like his mom and his in is
his dad or like you know stay quiet
don't like a PE you're gonna scare the
kid here we already being awake
basically goes into the bathroom where
there's all this blood if he looked into
the toilet and he sees this 17 foot
tapeworm and so basically Aunt Mary had
basically you know been suffering from a
tapeworm now things like dementia in
Alzheimer's I don't believe that the
byproduct of tapeworms it's usually
things like loss of appetite diarrhea
vomiting things along those lines but
the reason why this is important is
because it set the stage for huy
essentially being squeamish not really
being able to handle those things and
where he's talking to this guy Biggers
about this story you know he's just kind
of like this is the reason why i've real
always kind of had trouble with that
kind of stuff I've never really been a
strong guy that combined with the fact
that he was always kind of baby by his
parents meant that in reality he was
never really were not really ready for
the world he was not really made to
experience how tough life can really be
sometimes and so as a result of that
when he joined up on the boys he
basically ended up in a situation where
it was a total 180 right you had this
sheltered kid from Mountain Scotland who
always had his needs taken care of and
never really had to worry about anything
and had a couple girlfriends here and
there and that was basically it -
suddenly being in this world of violence
madness and absolute chaos which was
totally oblivious to up to that point in
time and so it's a it was a huge shift
and one that he wasn't really ready for
and indeed in a situation like that you
kind of have to be eased into it right
you can't just be thrown into the deep
end of the pool and expected to thrive
there and she doesn't work that way and
so of course he basically lashes out at
his mom when he gets back home he lashes
out at his mom with the fact that she's
kind of babying him a little bit it
really kind of drives him nuts he goes
to spend some more time with detergent
and Bobby sort of hanging out with them
and then once he gets back home he ends
up finding out that Annie's there that
Annie basically tracked him down to his
home in Scotland and came to visit him
and from there things get really really
cool because what you get here is this
origin of starlight like you get this
origin of Annie one of the things that
econo gone on there and that huge fight
between her and Huey is a lot of it was
one-sided right it was Annie asking him
please stop please stop saying these
things
let me explain let me tell you what was
going on let me give you my side of the
story and here we didn't want to hear it
but he wanted to stay angry he wanted to
be upset and he wanted to leave right so
he ultimately ended up bailing out Annie
coming here is for the purpose of saying
fine you know let's see if we can't find
some common ground and even if we can't
then let me tell you my story let me
tell you where it all came from so of
course what she tells us is that she was
born in in Des Moines Iowa and she was
born with superpowers which of course we
knew that all these little kids are
basically injected with compound V
during the gestation phase when it comes
to them you know basically growing you
know as a fetus in the mother's womb and
then when they give birth you know the
kids come out with powers sometimes have
powers manifests at birth sometimes they
don't but Annie's powers manifested the
day that she was born she admitted this
ultra bright light and blinded both of
her parents in the process and so
following that bought American
immediately became aware of what was
going on with Annie and then basically
told her parents look like we could make
life easy for you you know you guys
signed these in das will make sure that
you guys have all your needs taken care
of we'll provide you with seeing-eye
dogs all you have to do is give up your
child and that's exactly what they did
they basically signed away any and
ended up going into a foster home or at
least ended up being taken by Vaughn
American and kind of experimented on for
five years and then being sent to a
foster home
but these foster homes didn't really
exist for the purpose of like trying to
give them a stable lifestyle right
trying to like take them in and give
them a stable childhood so they could go
on to become productive members of
society these foster homes were really
more of like proving grounds insofar as
they would go to these pageants for
superheroes and what would happen is
they would dress her up and like a
superhero costume you know it was very
much like those those child pageants
right those travesties when when parents
marched their kids out there put him on
display for the world you know and kind
of stripped their childhood away and so
because of that like when when this
whole thing went down what you ended up
getting was like this kind of
performance right and Starlight played
her part the way she was supposed to as
she did her song she did her dance she
flew around you know she kind of lit up
a little bit but she couldn't do it
super bright otherwise she would blind
everybody but one of the other girls
there started to lose control of her
powers right her powers weren't working
the way the sewers of post tube and
actually ended up melting her eyes out
of her head right so not all of this
went the way it was supposed to and for
those parents whose children proved to
be superheroes where I proved to be
people that vote American could
basically use to kind of go into
superhero groups later on down the line
and things like that they were rewarded
handsomely for the parents of starlight
they were basically given everything
they needed from bought American
financially and otherwise to ensure that
their daughter grew up and being you
know used her powers and learned how to
use her abilities that everything's
along those lines whereas for the family
of this young girl whose eyes burned out
of their head fought American was just
like done kind of swept the whole thing
under the rug and that was the end of
that the parent should just kind of left
there right so in a lot of ways when it
came to these foster families the kids
were meal tickets and really nothing
more than that and so following that as
the years went by starlight eventually
found herself on the young Americans but
one of the funny things about this is
that the young Americans were not really
given any direction right and we knew
about this when it came to superheroes
we knew about that from the origin of
the superheroes right insofar as big
just went out there and did their thing
and that's really how odd American
treated the young Americans right
they're like okay so here's your
superhero team you guys are gonna be
together you guys are gonna gonna do
your thing here's your vote American
representative if you ever need to talk
to them here's your liaison for the
public eye so one is so forth go be
superheroes and that was basically yet
now the other part of this is that Huey
actually asks a really good question he
says if this was the case and this is
how you guys were being treated by blond
American then why not leave even if you
couldn't let yourself up you know in in
a super bright light that you could fly
you know that you had some measure of
super hearing depending on your
concentration why not say well I can
work for the hospital and I can
fly people right I can I can get a
person from an accident site back to the
hospital faster than a helicopter can
why didn't you ever do that and the
initial the statement of Starline is it
just never really crossed our minds
right like we just wanted to be one of
the superheroes right we were kind of
caught up in the moment and so the
result is that when vaud american had
them carry out these various campaigns
as superheroes at the end of the day
they didn't really allow them to work
with EMTs so I didn't really allow them
to do things like ferry people from from
accident sites to hospitals and the
reason why was because what it basically
did is it reduced the liability for an
American because superheroes were
basically funded by Vaughn American and
Vaughn was like the entity they kind of
kept him in the public eye they didn't
want to disrupt the flow of money if
Starlight was you know picked somebody
up and was going to fly them to the
hospital and that person became too
heavy and like she dropped them and they
died well then it would be a PR
nightmare for Vaughn American right it'd
be a public relations disaster and so it
would lead to problems so the idea was
don't do anything that can disrupt the
flow of money and so because of that
starlet and the young Americans their
job was to just be in the right places
at the right times and look like they
were doing things or in some cases do
things that seem to be worthwhile but
what it did is it kept him in the public
eye and it kept him looking good and so
in turn it kept the flow of money going
the other part of this is that you had
things where she you know she was part
of the whole belief system right the
capes for Christ how to preach in this
idea of Christianity and so on and so
forth all the while kind of feeling
herself continually removed from it
because she didn't really see him to to
believe in the ideas that she was
espousing but that's what she was
supposed to do that was the role she
played but understand there's a huge
difference between what's going on here
and what's going on with the seventh in
a lot of ways she was naive right she
didn't really understand what was really
going on with the whole superhero
community she didn't know how far down
this rabbit hole went it wasn't until
she joined the seven that she really
began to realize that how dark and how
screwed up things really are and so at
that point he just kind of says well I
mean you know that's that's a sad story
and everything and whatever but like it
doesn't really change anything and so
the response I saw it is well then tell
me how you actually got this footage and
he was responses well somebody emailed
it to me and so it's like yeah and then
you told me that Lee doesn't really make
any sense right somebody took some
footage that happened to be of the girl
that you were dating which only you and
I know that we were dating each other
somebody took footage of that exact time
period and then sent it to you that
means somebody had to know but if you
and I were the only ones who do know
then who else could have possibly known
and how could they have found out now of
course we know as the reader Billy
butcher gave it to Huey because Billy
butcher knows that Huey and Starr letter
day
because he we told him as much right but
starlight doesn't know the other side of
that coin she doesn't know the story of
Huey Huey is still telling lies right
he's still lying to her and so at that
point you know she's like well you know
coz that's that's that's what girls like
me do we do whatever we have to do in
order to get ourselves ahead right
that's what we do and it's just kind of
like damn like I mean she absolutely
lays into this sky you know and at that
point Huey the the the the idea of him
really kind of starts to fall apart
right this stance is this hard-line
stance that he took oh no no no you know
we're word world what we're done that
kind of thing it all starts to fall to
pieces right it all starts to go away
and it's one of these things where he
basically apologizes it says I never
really meant to say any of that I never
should have never should have said any
of it and Starlight says I know those
aren't things that you would really say
somebody fed you that right somebody
told you or somebody put those thoughts
in your head those aren't thoughts that
you came to of your own accord somebody
showed you this or somebody told you a
thing and in your desperation and in
your sadness you believed it and now
you're just parroting what somebody else
told you as I was kind of cool because
at that point like that's the truth of
the reality right the truth of the
scenario is that Billy butcher put the
idea in Huey's head no woman like that
would ever date you because look how hot
she is
and look how reasonably attractive you
are right like what could you possibly
have to offer her she could have anybody
what would she have you just so she can
spend time quote-unquote with the
commoners so she could say well I did
that too you know I slimmed it up with
the regular guys to once right you know
that's that's why she did all that Billy
butcher is the one that gave him that
footage instead of here you go you know
and put him in that vulnerable state in
the first place and then capitalize on
it to kind of turn Healey right but it
wasn't really done from a place of being
vindictive it was done from billy
butchers perspective you have to
understand what superheroes are like
right believed butcher does not believe
in good superheroes as far as he's aware
if a superhero goes the rest of their
life without turning into a villain it's
because they just didn't live long
enough let's believe witchers entire
stance and so following that while Huey
and Starlight are somewhat on better
terms in the senses she allowed herself
to kind of get all that frustration and
all that anger that she felt and to to
be allowed to tell her story there's a
kind of coldness there on behalf of Huey
and so far that she crashes in the guest
bedroom but when she gets up in the
morning whew he's there she's like
wanting to change and everything and he
was like okay I'll leave you to it he
treats her more like a friend as opposed
to somebody he's romantically connected
with and so because of that when he gets
you know back out of the house and you
know he's talking to his dad and and and
he's talking to his dad and that kind of
thing and you know his dad's like well
hey you should take Eddie around town
and and sure what's going on when that
happens Huey basically ends up taking
her
says look I thought about everything
that you said yesterday and I thought
about the things that I said and and
here's the deal
I get that everything that you did in
terms of from whatnot that was before
you met me technically it really isn't
and it isn't any of his business and
that's what he recognizes but what he
says is I can't get past this I cannot
get past this idea do you basically gave
guys a cut you know gave guys them in
order to get onto a superhero team I
can't get past that I can't get that out
of my head and because I cannot get that
out of my head
I can't be with you anymore but I just I
can't deal with this I can't cope with
this and so because that when Annie
asked the question where does that leave
us
here is like there's nothing here
anymore like we're not together anymore
we're done like we're we're over with
there's no romantic connection between
the two of us and so Wally they still
kind of seem to remain us seem to
maintain some measure of a friendship
what this does is it basically leads to
them you know heading back towards
heading back to the house and then of
course running into mr. Biggers again
and this is kind of a cool little thing
here right because vigor starts talking
to Annie and and the two of them kinda
get a little bit cordial with each other
you know and it figures like Romeo is
interesting you know of all the times
that I've talked to Hughie he's never
once brought you up right he's never
mentioned you or anything like that if I
had met you I never would have known you
existed in the first place which really
kind of speaks volumes right the fact
that he would cut somebody like that out
of his life in such a way though there
really doesn't does not seem to be any
kind of attachment there anymore right
there's no more romantic interest as far
as he's concerned she's a friend and
somebody that he used to date once and
that's it if she's even really
considered to be a friend at all and so
in the midst of this whole conversation
what is up happening is basically
Biggers tells Hughie well hey I ran into
your friend Bobby earlier today and and
basically like he tried to get ahold of
you by phone he wasn't able to do it but
he gave me this message told you to
basically go meet him you know and
around it around 10 o'clock so they do
you know once they end up meeting up
there of course Bobby shows up they're
believing Hughie summon him there so
right off the bat we kind of know what's
some some measure of a ruse there's
supposedly Hughie had sent a text to
Bobby saying meet me here at this
location in 10 o'clock now when they get
there of course what they end up
witnessing is this guy topper and his
various henchmen who were unloading
drugs and plane to smuggle them
throughout you know get them throughout
the the area of Scotland whether they
find out that detergents basically join
their group by detergents join their
team and so we're Bobby kind of screamed
off oh my god you know it's detergent
that in turn brings the attention of we
Sarah this big ol house of a woman who
in turn kind of starts attacking the two
of them now of course Bobby and and
Sarah get into a fight with each other
and then Bobby basically confronts
confronts detergent says you you have
any idea what you're doing this is
cocaine lace with Veatch you have any
clue
this is going to have on people now
again this hit to the idea that in this
small little island of Scotland are cut
off from the world so unless you were
actually out there in the way that Huey
was none of them really understand the
effects of what it is that they're doing
spreading this compound V lace cocaine
all throughout this area of Scotland is
gonna cause nothing but problems at that
point popper basically starts to freak
out pulls a gun and ends up pulling the
trigger but of course detergent jumps in
the way Shields Huey and detergent gets
shot instead and then seemingly somebody
comes out of nowhere and basically takes
out Sara [ __ ] you over the head with a
rock and then we end up finding out of
course that it's mr. bigger so it's
kinda like okay so Alastair Vickers like
there's more to this guy then initially
seem to be the case now of course this
leads to Huey basically tracking this
guy down chasing down topper who sprayed
in the mouth by a bird with all these
little bonnet and all that kind of stuff
basically he gets bombed like bird vomit
and puke and all this nasty garbage and
stuff in his in his mouth and they just
wants to be shot by the cops right when
the cops show up he's like just shoot me
now this is a horrible experience
alright which I kind of have to believe
is true right you know being being you
know having a bird project how vomit in
your mouth is probably one of the most
horrific experiences that anybody could
ever endure but of course not only that
you know they go to visit Bobby in the
hospital after it's all cleared up of
course you know detergent basically died
but they go to visit Bobby in the
hospital and Bobby's really just kind of
kind of like hey look I mean it could be
worse yeah we could certainly be a worse
experience I mean I'm kind of maimed a
little bit but I have my life you know
and that's kind of the important thing
there but give me a lot worse than this
so he's kind of seeing the bright side
of things right not really seeing the
worst side of things and so from there
you get this really cool conversation
that goes on between Huey and Annie and
of course Huey basically tells this
story where he talks her about the worst
thing that he ever did right the worst
thing that he's ever done throughout his
entire life now keep in mind it's
probably a true story but it's certainly
not the worst thing he's done but what
he talks about is how himself and Bobby
and detergent it come across this dog
there was stuck on a rock out in this
this out in this bog this little body of
water and that initially they were kind
of looking at it wondering how it was
that they got there and then Bobby
picked up a rock and threw it at the dog
and they started throwing rocks at it
seeing if they could hit it well then
suddenly like you know this dog starts
to freak out it ultimately falls off
starts to get carried away by the water
and or at least you know starts to kind
of drown in the water he reruns grabs it
picks it up and then basically take you
know takes it back to the original owner
now we don't really see who the owner is
we just see that Huey basically gives
you know gives the dog to the owner and
the owner gives him a bit of coin and
then like Amy starts to laugh at him
she's like if that's the worst thing
you've ever done then you have to
understand Huey like this idea of being
like this super hard-ass like
being cold to the world not really
caring about anybody or anything and is
kind of doing things your own way like
that's not really a source of strength
if you believe it is and somebody lied
to your ass there's basically what she
says she's like that's not really the
case like like being kind to people like
letting people in letting them
understand you're like how could you
ever hope to have a truly intimate
relationship if you never really let
people see who you really are at the end
of the day if you keep that part of
yourself hidden away from everybody well
then you and your entire relationship is
predicated on fear you're afraid they're
going to leave so you basically never
give them a reason to leave at least as
far as you're concerned but the reality
is not letting them see who you really
are means you don't trust them and if
you don't trust them then they're going
to leave so you're essentially setting
yourself up for failure and then all the
while you're gonna point the finger at
the fact that they left as a reason why
they can't be trusted
when you were to cause the problem in
the first place as it was it's
interesting because he kind of has to
come to grips with this fact that what
anna is asking of him in terms of having
a real tried and true relationship what
she needs from him is something more
than he seems to have been able to give
before that yes she gave guys a couple
of guys in order to get herself on a
superhero team but that was before he
met her right so unless he's looking to
date a woman who's never been intimate
with another guy before
good luck like he's gonna have to go
find some girl he's had a life his
sheltered his he has and he's like a
virgin in order to find that there's a
little bit of reality that has to come
into play there you know and so
ultimately he has to kind of come to
grips with this and so as a result when
he gets back home what he ends up doing
is talking to his parents they'd say of
course you know with this guy that guy
alastair bigger stop by for you ah you
know said he wasn't able to get ahold of
you but he went ahead and left this
message for you and basically is a piece
of paper with the with a phone number
and the name Mallory
now for those of you guys who were who
haven't really been following this
Mallory was one of the original members
of the boys the one who effectively quit
basically meaning that Alastair figures
is not his real name it is actually
Mallory the guy who originally put
together the voice team and whether or
not he was spying on Huey has yet to be
seen but all we know is that he's
basically committed been confiding in
this guy the entire time so it's kind of
curious to see how all that unfolds so
what you end up getting in this kind of
little tidbit here is Huey going about
doing his thing basically you know
heading out of Scotland alongside an E
and then boarding his bus but one of the
things he doesn't tell his parents is I
love you he doesn't say that to them
instead he still kind of used the ID and
he's still kind of angry at his parents
because they baby him so much but the
reality is that other people out there
have had these exceedingly hard laws and
if the biggest thing that Huey hates
about his parents is the fact that they
dote on him too much that's not a bad
thing to be upset about right there are
people out there who would love to have
that kind of relationship with their
parents but they don't right so it's
nothing to be angry about and Huey
really kind of comes to give of that
when he starts breaking down and crying
and saying that like he should lie he
should have told him he loved him should
have told that he cared about him he's
never really told them that before right
it's something that they've never really
heard from him and so because that is he
hasn't really appreciated them in the
way that he was supposed to and that of
course will become a pretty significant
pop point later on down in the story
what would that be said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain make sure
you guys with the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later
[Music]